there is a new heiress to the hilton  throne Nicky Hilton Rothschild and her  husband James welcomed their first child  a baby girl the 32 year old had been  eagerly awaiting her mini-me posting  updates about her pregnancy on Instagram  like this sweet shot prepping her  daughter's nursery last month  Paris Hilton through her sister this  swanky baby shower in New York couture  dresses fancy cakes and a bethany  frankel  it was one picture-perfect affair the  NYC soiree was actually Nikki's second  shower in May the heiress also  celebrated with her California crew in  Los Angeles which included her mini mini  cousins Nicky's bundle of joy arrived  almost exactly one year to the day of  her first wedding anniversary she and  James tied the knot in London England on  July 10